one of the things that you you've been
researching a lot more recently is artif
artificial intelligence um and I wonder
for people who are listening to this
like let's imagine someone like
everyone's heard of AI at this point
we've heard of we've all heard of chat
GPT um but I think going a level deeper
in understanding like what is it like
how did it get like how did it develop
over time and why is it that some people
have been talking about AI for like 10
plus years others have just heard about
it last year when Chad GPT got big
so I wonder is like can we start with
what is artificial intelligence like how
should we let's start at the beginning
sure uh even in in in Aristotle and
others there were uh in the in the Greek
mythology there were uh examples of uh
the idea of the of the robot human that
plays the liar and tills the fields
right so this is there's always been
this beautiful anthropomorphizing and
quest for the the other which could
either be the the mechanical human that
alleviates our toil and in fact the term
robot comes from Roboto which I think
means toil in cck you can check me and I
believe it was H come on who who who it
was are you are rostrom Universal robots
a play by
Carl KAIT is his name uh from about
1920 all of your right now all of your
listeners are pausing and and going on
Google to find me out I'm a fraud okay
but I'm close enough um and so uh or
also the idea of the Golem or the
Frankenstein monster we not only
anthropomorphize but we create our evils
and embed it in it as well so we've
always had this um idea that we could
have an artificial being that would
resemble a human being but it was Alan
Turing who sort of gave us our initial
construction of it first on paper on
computable numbers identifying that
there could be a universal Computing
machine which would which I fully don't
understand it would take too long to
truly to explain but and that was around
1935 or so and then around 19 I want to
say about 1950 uh he writes uh the paper
in the psychology Journal interesting
that mind uh on the imitation game in
which he talks about this introduces the
Turing test later to be called the
Turing test there it was the conceptual
idea that we need to program computers
that can make decisions like a human
would make decisions so suddenly it purs
it asked the question how do humans make
decisions and so there was a whole
movement around from the 1950s to the
1990s to take the ways that human makes
humans make decisions and enshrine that
into computers that's through the
hardware and more importantly through
the software and the hardware is pretty
simple in fact we use our computer
hardware analog to the human mind in
which we have a we have memory and we
have a processor right something that
stores information and something that
uses information to come up with an
input and then an output and an answer
and and the original computers were made
on the model of the human mind okay but
then we also had to create a system in
which we were going to render into
software the ways in which humans made
decisions so we think sequentially and
we think rationally so if we create a
long list and the original programming
language of AI was called lisp for list
programming we could simply write down
all the rules that we use as heuristics
in terms of making decisions to get our
output that seemed logical it was deeply
deeply flawed and the reason why is
humans don't think sequentially like we
we're a jumble of ideas all at once we
do we think rationally well we spent the
last 25 years in cognitive Psychology
and Neuroscience to look at all the ways
that we don't think rationally that we
actually
embed cognitive biases through
everything that we do so that was
actually that showed promise and it got
us so far but no further the early gains
became like Fool's Gold we thought we
were getting closer and closer but then
became harder and harder and harder to
wreak out any benefit of it so what
happened during this period and then we
had these ideas called the AI winter
this was in the 70s ' 80s and then later
in the '90s there was one two or three
depending on how you count these but the
I the broader point is that these
Winters were When government funding and
Industry funding shriveled up for AI and
right about the year 2000 2005 if you
said you worked on AI in Academia you
got laughed at and couldn't get a tenure
and couldn't get a post because it just
seemed like again it was a Fool's
Quest all right question on this front
yeah so computer working out that 2 plus
2 equals 4 that's not AI great question
let's let's let's pause the the the my
my discourse to say I'm going to
introduce this concept of machine
learning and Stat what's really a
shorthand for statistical machine
learning and changing the method to go
into that nice so 2 + 2 = 4 is um is a
truth it's almost like a almost like a
ukian sort of um uh Foundation right
it's it's basic arithmetic of the the
origin of mathematics um we should also
say is a little bit trickier still
because at the outset it didn't it took
took several centuries before we
Millennia before we have the concept of
zero right so we started with one right
we needed a zero and Discovery was
important but that's simply to say that
we needed imagination and and a
conceptual shift to understand
mathematics but we have a one and we
have a two okay we have a 2 plus 2 equal
4 if we can in if we can enshrine that
into a computer that can generate that
same answer all the time and then can
actually conceptu have an idea that
anything with one added to it becomes
one more sequential that would be AI
right it's by definition it's it's
intelligent or however we want to Define
intelligence we could talk forever about
it and it's artificial the key thing the
sort of the one of the earliest
aphorisms in AI was that we call AI
anything we cannot do once we know how
to do it we call it a calculator or we
call it a uh a search engine or we call
it voice nition or we call self-driving
cars but the frontier of what we can't
do we refer to as Ai and then when we
have it it's like oh that that oh that
oh that's just a search engine yeah oh
that's nothing like that's simple I'm
used to that right but of course it's
you know Google itself is absolutely
remarkable the reason why is the
explicit versus the implicit a world in
which we're trying to design and the
world of lisp and AI proper the or
original of the origin of AI by when the
coin was termed in 1955 at a conference
at Dartmouth by Marvin Minsky and John
McCarthy among others there was about
three people from Britain there one of
them part of the selfes family by the
bye that there it was about explicitly
instructing a computer a set of
instructions to program it on if I give
you big uh decision tree if I give you
these instructions to do this you
therefore produced this output and I've
got full explainability I can see on a
piece of paper the program that I've
then introduced into the computer okay
the shift that happened
um weirdly enough around that time in
the late 40s early 50s there was several
people Frank rosenblat is is one of them
who died prematurely several years later
in his 30s uh they looked at a different
technique and that was to apply
statistics to the problem collect the
data have the machine make an inference
modeled on the human mind on the neural
network of the human mind with nodes and
and a decision layer sounds a little bit
like deep learning so what happened is
that the the the Grandes of AI it's like
an academic squabble in this case Marvin
Minsky and John McCarthy at MIT and then
later at Berkeley looked at this issue
and said oh that's never going to work
and they were not wrong they were right
it wasn't going to work because of the
constraints in computer processing power
and memory and cost at the time but
everyone went through the the
instruction based of AI classical what
was called GOI good oldfashioned AI GOI
and they they tried to embed the a large
decision-making Tree on how to make
decisions expert system is another term
for it at the same time this weird
method that was poo pooed and no one had
any trust in around the 80s and the 90s
and the year 2000s was a statistical
machine learning just give the machine a
lot of data let it work out the system
for itself and make an inference you
don't need to know all of the ways in
which it can find these variables and
co-variables and coefficients to
identify why it makes a decision under
these conditions in fact it's so
intricate that it would exceed our human
capacity to grock how to do that but the
effect is that it works and it works
better than alternative systems take
images if show it lots of IM if I
describe a cat as having hair having
ears having a tail having almond shaped
eyes and whiskers that's great what if
I'm looking at the cat that doesn't have
a tail from behind how do I know it's a
cat right the answer is I'd have to
program and say oh here's the exception
what if it's like this like that right
it's crazy to come You' never the real
world is such you'd never have enough
ability to create all these these
exceptions give it you know a quarter of
a trillion wouldn't be that many but
several million examples of cats under
all lightings all conditions all kind of
cats ask if it's a cat or not it can do
it it's statistical right that method
was totally you know not part of the
research agenda but it showed promise
and it was so effective there was really
only three people in the world who were
the leading lights and their students
who were pursuing this sort of
ridiculous ambition one's named Jeffrey
Hinton the other one's named Yoshi Benjo
the Third is named yan laon yan Lon
became the head of AI at Facebook Hinton
at Google Yoshi Benjo stayed uh in
Montreal in Academia but became an
adviser to companies they won the
touring award a couple years ago the
term deep learning and the AI revolution
of around
2012 was and this was Grace of them
there was other people Peter norvig and
Russell Stewart and uh Stuart Russell
and others the key is this they re
framed AI from trying to give it
explicit rules to giving it information
and the the computer coming up with its
own set of rules through an inference it
wasn't explicit it was now implicit hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye